[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: One of
the interesting parts
about building an
Android application is
all the awesome configurations
of screen sizes and form
factors.
And if you're a developer
who prides themselves
on being available on the
most devices possible,
then chances are you've got a
lot of your images and icons
at each specific resolution
that you need to support.
But be warned, this might
be causing a large issue
with the size of your APKs.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And if you're trying to
squeeze the last byte out
of your APK file size,
then VectorDrawables
are a handy solution.
See, one of the big
problems with images
that you include in your
APK is that you end up
needing to have multiple
versions of the same image
at various resolutions.
And that's because file
types like PNG and JPEG
are what we call
raster graphics.
They define a 2D
grid of pixel data
that's pretty much copy pasted
to the screen when it's drawn.
So to get different
resolutions, you
have to create an entirely
new file at that resolution
and place it in your APK.
The result is that the more
images you have to include,
the larger APK size is.
This is where
VectorDrawables come in.
Rather than having to store
an image for each resolution
you support, VectorDrawables
allow you to use one file
and generate whatever
resolution you need on demand.
It works like this.
A VectorDrawable
file creates a bunch
of shapes and their
visual properties--
like type, the position, the
color, the rotation, et cetera,
et cetera.
When you load a
VectorDrawable file,
the system draws each
shape to the screen,
giving you your final image.
And since it's just
drawing shapes,
you can do this at
any size you'd like.
Meaning, a single VD
file inside of your APK
can let you generate MDPI,
HDTPI, and XXXHDPI images,
greatly reducing your APK bloat.
Oh, by the way,
another cool thing.
You can define animations
on VectorDrawables,
which means instead of keeping
each frame of your animation
logged out at each
resolution you support,
you can simply
set up an XML file
that transforms the
graphic in the same way,
giving a similar visual
result with much less resource
overhead.
Now, it's worth pointing
out while VectorDrawables
can save you some size,
there's a few caveats
you need to consider
when using them.
Firstly, loading VectorDrawables
in your app at runtime
isn't the same as
loading a JPEG.
While JPEGs have hardware
decoders to help unpack things,
VectorDrawables
need to be generated
through successive draw
commands to the GPU.
See, every shape in a VD file
has to be rendered to a texture
before the final image
can be used on screen.
This means that the bigger
the image that you have
and your generating or the
more complex the drawable is,
the more time it's going
to take to load your image.
But just like JPEGs or PNGs, you
only pay that cost at runtime.
Rendering a VD later is just
as cheap as any other graphics
resource.
Secondly, in order
for VectorDrawables
to represent complex
images, you have
to add a lot of complex shapes.
This impacts both the size
of the VectorDrawable file
and the amount of time it takes
to load the image at runtime.
As such, it makes sense that
VectorDrawables are best
used for images with
low amounts of details
that are trivially simple to
represent which shape elements.
While PNGs and JPEGs might be
able to compress those images
quite well, the more simple
the image, the more savings
that VDs will give you.
Finally, make sure that you
keep an eye on the complexity
of the paths in the file.
See, most of the
time when you're
creating shape information
from an external tool,
it can go the extra
mile to insert
lots of additional points or
path information which may not
be required in order to produce
the desired visual output.
By simplifying your
path data before adding
the VectorDrawable
to your app, you'll
reduce the amount of file
size these items take up
in your final APK.
And that's kind of the trick
with performance, right?
I mean, catching
all the crazy stuff
before it gets out of hand?
Which is why you should check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns videos.
And don't forget to join
our Google+ community to ask
questions to the other experts.
So keep calm; profile your
code; and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]